hey what is up guys mkbhd here i get
asked a lot of tech questions but the
one that constantly comes up is what's
your daily stuff and what's on your
phone and this tends to be something i
regularly get asked and even though i've
done this video before
i didn't do this video over and over
again because what's on my phone was
mostly the same through school but this
is the first year where i'm not a
full-time student so my priorities have
changed a little bit and the setup's a
little different now just a little bit
so let's do it now i do still have two
sim cards uh both are a t one of them is
my primary sim which is the phone number
everyone has and the other is my
secondary sim nobody has that number
it's just for review phones so when i'm
reviewing a phone i move all
communications except texting and
calling to the review phone i still
carry both phones but now i take photos
and observe battery life and do
everything i can on the review phone and
if it's good enough then it'll move up
to become my main phone and it gets my
main sim and repeat that process every
time an interesting new smartphone comes
out the main sim right now is in a nexus
6p the secondary sim right now is in a
next bit robin so you already know what
that means so this is my nexus 6p uh if
you've seen any other what's on my phone
videos that'll look familiar i'll lick
to the skin i have on it below most
metal phones really don't need a skin
but i like the way this one looks so
there you have it and yes the wallpaper
i'm rocking will be linked right below
that like button if you're looking for
that too and this is the setup it's a
pretty clean stock look uh google
launcher and honestly the better these
stock apps get the less i have to rely
on third-party stuff for extra
functionality plus i keep this setup
pretty simple and clean since i have to
be able to quickly set it up when i move
to a new device so up top on the main
home screen i have this widget with the
forecast and the temperature it's called
buzz widget and they have a whole
launcher and a whole bunch more ways to
customize stuff but i just have this
simple one here linking to a weather app
because it's clean so that just sits
there looking pretty and then below that
you have all the most used apps so right
off the bat you probably have the two
most frequent used the music apps so i
have soundcloud and spotify and i have
public profiles for both and i use both
i listen to a lot of music a lot of
playlists all that sort of stuff i also
have g tasks for google tasks and google
keep a lot of people ask why do i have
both i use tasks just for like my to-do
list so literally things i need to get
accomplished by a certain time or day
and then google keep is more of like a
notes app for lists things to remember
there's also a folder of google apps
that i use most often and then the
youtube studio app which i probably open
like every day i reply to comments i
check up on things i use youtube studio
all the time the myfitnesspal app and
pocket which is a link aggregator sort
of like a pocket of saving links so if i
see something i want to come back to i
drop it in pocket and then of course at
the bottom you can't forget the dock
with the most important stuff so i have
the phone the messenger the camera app
of course and i use phoenix for twitter
so that's my go-to twitter app and it
kind of has been for a while i know
there's a couple others that are now you
know pretty similar to it but in terms
of functionality and simplicity pretty
much can't go wrong with phoenix anyway
that's pretty much it for the main home
screen as you can see it's familiar but
functional and then just to the right of
that i'm still rocking this full screen
widget so this widget is called the
today calendar widget it basically takes
my google calendar and makes it
scrollable and just this layout of all
my calendar events for the day and i use
google calendar a lot so i'm always
swiping over here to make sure i know
where i'm at for the day
and that's it that's the whole two
screen setup for the way i keep my
android phone nothing too crazy of
course all the way over to the left of
those home screens there's google now
and all my cards i use google voice
search all the time from the home screen
but the cards are pretty useful too
looks like clippers beat the spurs the
other night so that's pretty dope and
yeah i feel like pretty much anyone can
emulate this setup if they wanted to
real quick i'll hop over into my app
drawer for some other apps that i don't
have on my home screen so not a billion
apps or anything as you can tell but uh
i do let's see i have apple music i
don't really use it that much but i have
it because you know soundcloud and
spotify are obviously really good i got
some pretty standard stuff in between i
do have the yahoo fantasy sports app uh
currently dominating in nba fantasy
league if you're wondering no big deal
also i do have a little bit of a
phillips hue setup going on in my office
as you probably already know i've been
considering checking out lifx which is a
very similar thing after some
recommendations of it but i also saw a
pretty baller looking beta hue app
coming up soon so i want to check that
out before i switch up my hardware
there's also the nba game time app i
have league pass i watch clipper games
go clippers
uh
periscope do people still periscope i
stole periscope sometimes i feel like
whenever i log on there there's not a
whole lot happening but every once in a
while i do a live show for whatever fun
reason we come up with worth following
there over on periscope if you haven't
already i also have this app called
screener so this is pretty cool i'll
show you actually you can basically make
really pretty looking home screen
showcase images just by inserting it
onto an image of the actual device so
you pick your device and then you go
down into your gallery and you choose
your screenshot and then it'll drop that
screenshot image nicely onto a clean
shareable image of your phone i don't
know it's a lot prettier than just
showing the screenshot you know anyway
rounding it out you have relay pro for
reddit um
snapchat you should totally follow me on
snapchat it's pretty much the only place
i post behind the scenes and other
random stuff that disappears within 24
hours so snapchat story is where it's at
and then we have vsco cam when i'm
feeling fancy although instagram's
editing tools have been good enough for
me 90 of the time and then zillow since
i'm looking for a new place like
constantly
and that's what's on my phone there you
go any suggestions or apps you feel i
should know about definitely let me know
feel free to drop them in the comments
section and i'll have an eye out for
those thanks for watching and i'll talk
to you guys in the next one
peace
you